she's dabbled in fantasy and science
fiction and lived to tell the tale well
almost lived here's where you've seen
Katya from John Wick 4 before the
casting in the live-action Harry Potter
films was pretty perfect across the
board including the addition of Natalia
tena's nymphador talks don't call me
nymphadora
debuting in Harry Potter and the Order
of the Phoenix in 2007. tonk's married
tortured werewolf and former defense
against the dark arts teacher Remus
Lupine while not as prominent to
character as in the books tennis
certainly made her Mark in the franchise
until her heartbreaking exit with her
on-screen husband in Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows part 2. Tena
revealed that prior to every appearance
she made in Harry Potter movies she
would have vivid dreams about the world
she was helping bring to life before
filming began for Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows part 1 she told the Los
Angeles Times blog hero complex I
started having insane dreams again
whenever I start a Potter film I get
these dreams the last dream I had I was
in a war and the sky was blotted with
broomsticks and I couldn't find my wand
it was so intense I always have mental
intense War wizard dreams when I'm doing
the films an undeniable platform for a
plethora of talent before it took a
nosedive in its final season Game of
Thrones had a series of Stars Come and
Go including Natalia Tena is fleeing
wildling OSHA appearing for 16 episodes
in HBO's award-winning show she played
one of the few wildlings that made it
across the wall to escape the white
walkers but she was thrown back into the
madness when she became the protector of
Brandon Stark like many likable
characters on the show OSHA's time
didn't stretch as long as others and it
didn't take long before her exit to
figure out it was on the cards speaking
to inverse Tana pinpointed exactly when
she got the hint that her time on the
show was ending saying I was so excited
in season six when they brought me back
I'd been out for two or three seasons
they were like don't worry she's gonna
come back unfortunately it was when she
returned to film scenes with iwan rayon
who played The Psychotic villain Ramsay
Bolton that she realized her number was
up after seeing that she was only
filming for two weeks following her
return it didn't take long to connect
the dots that's when I clocked they're
definitely killing me off because I only
had my scenes with him and it's very
little to build on so I was like okay
I'm dying checking off three of the
biggest IPS in her career so far after
wandering around Westeros and appearing
alongside Harry Potter Natalia Tana had
a brief but just This brilliant time in
a galaxy far far away appearing as a
twilight in the world dominating show
the Mandalorian brushing shoulders with
the best guard-plated protagonist tenna
played xion part of a team of
mercenaries Dan is forced to team up
with in the show's sixth episode of its
debut season while she may have been
recognized in other projects here she's
hiding in plain sights as an iconic
alien species from the franchise with
the lengthy lekku to match a species at
first debuted in Star Wars Episode 6
Return of the Jedi in the form of bib
Fortuna and Jabba's slave girl that Leia
briefly replaced Twilights have become a
common species that have made
appearances and extended chapters of
Star Wars lore currently xi'an's outcome
was left unknown following the episode
with mixed Mayfield the only character
from that band of bad but potentially
good guys making a comeback since then
there has been no mention of din's
former flame but given just how big that
Galaxy is there's still a chance she
could turn up somewhere else in the
future to cause as much trouble as she
did here
thank you